all right this is a pepper panic saga
crates tutorial
um they changed the way that the crates
worked so i had to replace the old video
um
crates first come around in level 206
and so they're in all the levels on and
off after that
and um
they just got made a little bit simpler
now
it used to be that you could
only get you couldn't get rid of them by
making explosions next to them
but now
that'll actually
take them out too so
you can make matches like you can see
here i'll make a three
three pepper match right here and that's
gonna knock these
stage threes it's going to turn them
into like stage twos
and then eventually they'll get to be
stage one like these ones at the bottom
and then they'll disappear they've got a
pepper inside
you can read all about that in our guide
if you if you're seeing this video here
check the link
to uh
read all the details about that but
basically how they work is they have a
pepper inside
they can be stage one two and three
and when you make a match next to them
it knocks them down then we got an extra
match there so you can see they went
from stage three all the way down to
stage one
so if i make this three pepper match
here
it'll it'll release the peppers that are
inside of these crates on top
all right so another thing you want to
pay attention to on crates levels
real quick is what colors come out of
them all right because if you look at
our
collections over here we need to get 22
purple peppers but there aren't any here
yet
so that means that they're inside
these crates somewhere and they won't
start to fall from the top until we
release them so definitely read the
guide about that because that explains
that a whole lot more
but um so we made a match next to him
now we're going to make a shock wave
going down with this four pepper match
you're going to see that it's going to
hit this one crate right here
and it knocked it down
um
to a stage one
so the shock waves damaged them a little
bit more than
the
matches do
that's also new
so
the only other
well we'll show we'll make an explosion
here in a second but i'm going to clear
out some space first so just watch how
these move down
and if i can i'm gonna try to set up a
uh
a five pepper match all right so you saw
there that that explosion happened and
the one sitting to its corner
disappeared
and we'll do another one
as soon as we can get these all right
yeah so we'll explode this red pepper
and it's going to hit this one over here
and it opens it up
again here's another shock wave and this
one's going to actually have an
explosion too so watch how that affects
these
stage twos done under here
you see it the shock wave opened it up
and then the explosion knocked it down
one stage so the shock waves the
quickest way to get through them but all
these other ways work too as you can see
there i matched them knocked them down
another shock wave here another
explosion there and now you can see our
purple peppers are starting to to pop
out
so the other thing that we need to look
at is
how the super shock wave from the match
5 works
so
i got these yellow ones here they're
going to get in the way
this might take a second to set this up
yeah see before whenever you had a panic
that didn't that didn't cause any damage
to this to the crates at all it was a
little bit more of an interesting
feature at that point really
they're still cool but
it's just there's just not as much to
them anymore since they changed them i
guess they may have changed they changed
them because they wanted to be easier to
understand
they've been changing a lot of things
lately to make the game more player
friendly i suppose
um which is good overall
a lot of us who played it
the other way we liked it how it was i
guess so so
take some getting used to
all right so
i got that in the cascade um it would
probably happen a little bit quick
i'll see if i can get another one but
you see that whenever the five pepper
match happened up top it cleared out
every cage in its path a normal shock
wave will hit the first one
and stop
another one of the changes that they
made recently was the uh
the the power of the the
the match five shockwave um it didn't
even used to make a shock wave at all
before
and um now it does and it's the kind of
shock wave that travels through the
obstructions
we're going to make another one right
here but it's the that
row is already cleared so it's not
really going to illustrate the point
maybe we'll get one in the top or
something
it's going to be hard to actually set it
up on this board now that the um
now that those are going to be on
but basically that's that's how it works
um i'm not going to make this video any
longer it's pretty simple
if you need to go back and look at what
happens when that that match 5 the match
5 shock wave is really really important
now and it um it can help it makes a lot
of the levels easier
so
if you if you have a big group of
obstructions whether it be ice
crates
or cages or anything in your way you
know
petrified peppers whatever it is
look to make a shock five it goes in
both directions now and it goes straight
through and it'll hit everything behind
the obstruction so it's really useful
so i hope this helps explain how crates
work if you have any questions leave a
comment
make sure you
like the video if you found it helpful
visit our website to keep up to date
with everything new that's coming out in
the game
thanks